à ceux qui arrivent et ceux qui ont déjà
mis leur bulletin dans l'urne dans ce
bureau de vote du centre de dijon pas de
forte affluence mais le flot des
électeurs aura été régulier toute la
journée à 17 heures 70% des inscrits
avaient voté
pour beaucoup ne pas venir était
impensable des gens qui sont morts pour
ça donc je pense que c'est c'est plus
qu'important qu'aller voter donné sa
voix pour un candidat qui qui peut nous
nous correspondre
une élection depuis les droits de vote
on s'est battu pour avoir le droit de
vote faut quand même le respecter et
puis en plus faut donner notre peau
parce que si on donne pas notre mois
après on n'a pas de rouspéter
face à ces électeurs avant de passer
dans l'isoloir 12 bulletins avec les
noms des douze candidats un choix
difficile à faire chacun a donc dû
trouver sa solution permettront je suis
un peu renseigné quand même votre pas on
fait pas tout neuf quoi
je me suis tout simplement pencher sur
je n'ai pas refait il ya deux mois un
jury fait dans la semaine et voilà une
petite feuille des thématiques et j'ai
noté chaque candidat j'ai compté ray
j'ai pris celui qui avait la meilleure
attaque je me suis basé sur déjà la
photo tout vêtement le programme les
idées récemment
c'est la façade extérieure de la façade
intérieure c'est en tout donner et
prendre en ligne de compte selon ce que
je ressentais pour ce premier tour les
dés sont désormais jetés et dans deux
semaines il faudra de nouveau faire un
choix il devrait être plus facile avec
seulement deux candidats